rescuers in Thailand have brought all 12
members of the youth soccer team and
their coach out of a cave where they
were trapped for 18 days that's right
the last of the five people who were
still stuck underground were brought out
of the cave a short time ago and they
are being taken to a hospital you can
see the ambulances there the first-aid
boys are rescued on Sunday and Monday
are recovering this morning doctors say
they are in good spirits Anna Warner is
near the rescue scene in Chiang Rai
Thailand Anna good morning good morning
and they you know they couldn't have
done any better on this rescue what an
amazing effort that they've managed to
pull off here you know the world has
been watching this rescue mission for
two weeks
this whole these whole events in the
cave first wondering would they find the
team then once they were found wondering
how and if they could even rescue them
from the cave now today 19 divers went
in once again taking part to rescue the
remaining boys and their coach the team
will now undergo physical and mental
evaluations at the hospital they've been
trapped since June 23rd when they
explored the cave after soccer practice
and it was intense pressure to get these
boys out before heavy rains made this
dangerous operation even riskier divers
and consultants came from around the
world to help get the boys out including
the US Britain Australia China Japan
Finland and Belgium the boys in the
hospital they're expected to be there
for at least 7 days they're being
quarantined and two may have lung
infections but tonight we're learning
that the first the parents of the first
group of four boys actually have been
allowed into the same room with their
sons they had to stand two metres away
and wear protective gear like face masks
but they did get into the room with them
for the second group they have also seen
their boys but through a glass window so
that's good news for the parents has to
be a huge relief John
and a Warner in Thailand thanks a huge
relief indeed